with the launch of psvr2 comes a new
update for No Man's Sky adding VR2
support but just as importantly a bevy
of new features so even if you don't
have your hands on Sony's slick new
hardware there's still some new content
in the game to be enjoyed like with any
big no man's Sky update this one has a
very cool name fractal the standout
feature is integration with psvr too
adding haptic feedback features that
take advantage of the new hardware sense
controllers up to 4K resolution when
exploring the Galaxy and other gameplay
enhancements unique to the Sony headset
increased draw distance denser foliage
terrain tessellation and Reflections are
some of the new visual options that
users can expect which are complemented
by intelligent eye tracking headset
vibrations and 3D audio support
developer hello games does say that the
VR experience across the board has been
improved so those playing on PC with a
PC based VR headset will also see some
improvements including a better personal
force field controls than allow for more
intuitive options to deflect enemy
attacks revamped Target sweep and Hot
Spot surveying controls for the analysis
visor and several other quality of life
improvements beyond the core VR update
there's also a new Utopia speed of
Starship to collect this spacecraft has
increased travel speed when exploring a
planet's surface and can be obtained by
completing all of the Utopia Foundation
assignments there's also a new fearsome
visor to unlock for your spacesuit which
definitely doesn't look like it was
stolen from Darth Vader's Armory you can
even get a drone companion as well as
other rewards as part of the new
campaign like every previous no man's
Sky update fractal will be free for
anyone that already owns the game if you
did manage to snag a psvr2 headset and
need some games to test it out Gran
Turismo 7 is currently discounted to 40
the game having just launched full VR
capability dry Drive every car and race
on every track in the virtual world but
even if you aren't picking up a headset
this is a great deal for a great game
regardless if you've been watching HBO's
excellent adaptation of the last of us
but haven't pulled the trigger on the
original game's gorgeous PS5 re-release
The Last of Us Part 1 can now be picked
up for just fifty dollars a 20 discount
from when the game launched last
September other notable discounts
include Ratchet and Clank Rift apart for
thirty dollars death stranding directors
cut for 20 and Horizon forbidden West
for thirty dollars although the latter
two are available via the PS plus extra
and premium tiers if you're a subscriber
to either of those for a full list of
all the currently discounted PS5 games
head to the link in the description are
you going to be checking out no man's
Sky new big update in psvr 2 let us know
in the comments below and we'll see you
here for more Gamespot news